monarchia o di 10 milioni 709mila 423
numeri e abbiamo vinto molto bello
ruotano su file repubblica voti 12
milioni e 718 mila 19 st oggi l'italia è
proprio la mamma la mamma si sente male
gamma mons vieni andiamo generale la
suprema corte è che la maggioranza non
piangere può farlo non tutte battuto bay
che ci metta
[Musica]
chi è il coraggio di vivere che si viva
il re evviva canarie chimica non si
presti a provocazione di elementi
faziosi nella sicurezza che nessuno
potrà più strapparvi la vittoria che
facevano ce ne dobbiamo andare
la consultazione si mangiava facendo il
governo sappia che garante
[Musica]
grazie
alla tua assoluta mi ha detto
[Musica]
no gli auguri
allora buonasera fare memoria significa
rivivere e significa vivere quindi
raccontare 70 anni di storia della
repubblica significa fare un viaggio
breve ma spero emozionante suoni musiche
e parole immagini il racconto che poi è
il nostro mestiere il mio mestiere il
mestiere del giornalista raccontare
allora quella notte che ci fa vedere
dino risi in un film strepitoso e
indimenticabile una una vita difficile
con alberto sordi e lea massari ci fa
rivivere quella notte di 70 anni fa la
notte del referendum tra repubblica e
monarchia un rumore un rumore una
colonna sonora di quella notte è quella
che descrive carlo levi nel romanzo
l'orologio la notte a roma parti sentir
ruggire leoni un mormorio indistinto il
respiro della città quel suono insieme
vago e selvatico crudele ma non privo di
una strana dolcezza il ruggito dei leoni
nel deserto notturno delle case era un
paese distrutto le macerie ea roma si
sentivano ruggire i leoni intanto nella
notte tra il 4 il 5 giugno 1946 ormai si
era votato da qualche giorno si era
votato il 2 giugno ancora non si
sapevano i risultati i giornali di
quella sera pubblicavano righe di un
comunicato ufficiale in cui si
smentivano le voci e si diceva non
scrivete niente perché ancora non
sappiamo nulla
non c'erano gli exit poll che
sbagliavano non c'erano le bandierine
non si sapeva nulla e ci giravano voci
incontrollabili
alle nove di sera la monarchia era data
in vantaggio però per soli 20 mila voti
poi a un certo punto che abbia tutto
si comincia a dire che ha vinto la
repubblica si vocifera che re umberto e
scappato a fregene
e lì si è suicidato anche questo non era
vero
finalmente vengono convocati i
giornalisti al viminale e il ministro
degli interni giuseppe romita legge i
risultati un giornalista americano cerca
di sbirciare il foglietto dove ci sono
segnati i numeri e il ministro
spazientito erano giorni difficili gli
dà uno scappellotto è l'unico gesto di
violenza di quel giorno storico per
fortuna e abbiamo visto in quella scena
l'italia è un paese di faziosità
politica di guerre civili e all'epoca
alla guerra civile una guerra cruenta
c'era stata davvero però è anche un
paese dove poi ci si incontra a tavola
tra monarchici e repubblicani i
partigiani molto affamati che
festeggiano così quella sera la
repubblica nasce così senza applausi
senza bandiere e addirittura si fa un
concorso per vedere quale sistema
mettere nel tricolore
poi alla fine si decide di non mettere
nulla in modo dimesso in punta di piedi
eppure dirà pietro calamandrei nella
repubblica nella costituzione c'è dentro
tutta la nostra storia ha tutto il
nostro passato tutti i nostri dolori le
nostre sciagure le nostre gioie sono
tutti sfociati qui in questi articoli a
sapere intendere dietro questi articoli
si sentono delle voci lontane nicola che
c'entra nicola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è una scena di c'eravamo tanto amati di
ettore scola un bellissimo film vi
confesso uno dei miei preferiti
in particolare quando nino manfredi da
un pugno a vittorio gassman che gli ha
rubato la sua donna stefania sandrelli e
dice gassman gli dice pensavo che tu
fossi buono generoso e lui dice se siamo
stufati desse buoni e generosi
le musiche di armando trovajoli questa
scena di piazza caprera una piazza nel
quartiere trieste a roma ci fa passare
30 anni di storia dal bianco e nero al
colore e sono 30 anni in cui c'è di
tutto si passa dalle macerie alla
ricostruzione sono anni di cortei di
madonne piangenti di fronti popolari di
comitati civici di addavenì baffone di
aridatece er puzzone sono anni di
crescita di miracolo non solo economico
di terra ai contadini di valigie di
cartone di antenne di autostrade del
sole di sorpassi in cui tutto cresce la
produzione media il reddito medio
le auto in circolazione gli
elettrodomestici la media oraria del
giro d'italia e luciano bianciardi
scriverà io mi oppongo quassù io non ero
venuto per far crescere le medie e i
bisogni e sono gli anni del boom
economico la notte piccola per noi
troppo piccolina nel blu dipinto di blu
volare e la classe operaia andava il
paradiso sono gli anni degli angeli di
far del fango delle contestazioni gli
anni della meglio gioventù gli anni in
cui l'obbedienza non era più una virtù
sono anche gli anni di tre di trame
occulte di collusioni di patti oscuri
con la mafia di uomini piccoli che si
iscrivono alla loggia massonica p2 e
sfilano di fronte a una donna grande
tina anselmi
di speranze e disillusioni e di
passeggiate come questa di una pagina di
leonardo sciascia ieri sera uscendo con
la roma passeggiata ho visto nella crepa
di un muro una lucciola non ne vedevo in
questa campagna da almeno 40 anni le
lucciole le chiamavamo camila e di di
picuraru così i contadini le chiamavano
le candeline del pecoraro e ogni tanto
ne prendevamo qualcuna la tenevamo
delicatamente chiusa nel pugno per poi
aprirne a sorpresa tra i più piccoli di
noi quella fosforescenza smeraldina era
proprio una lucciola nella crepa del
muro le bio la gioia intensa come doppia
e come sdoppiata la gioia di un tempo
ritrovato e di un tempo da trovare da
inventare una passeggiata immaginaria
quella di sciascia una passeggiata
immaginaria come questa che adesso
vediamo
[Musica]
e il sogno della scena finale di
buongiorno notte di marco bellocchio il
sogno di aldo moro interpretato da
roberto di lisca libero che scappa dal
covo delle br e passeggia libero che le
strade di roma
chissà cosa sarebbe successo se
veramente quella passeggiata ci fosse
stata aldo moro è nato qui in salento
maglie il 23 settembre del 1916 cento
anni fa aveva 30 anni quando fu eletto
deputato alla costituente e scrisse la
costituzione
il suo rapimento il suo omicidio
rappresentano uno spartiacque tra la
generazione dei padri e quella dei figli
dopo sono arrivate altre cesure altre
rotture drammatiche tangentopoli falcone
e borsellino la bomba della stazione di
bologna e poi è arrivato negli anni più
recenti il terrorismo islamico all 11
settembre 2001 il 13 novembre 2015 e noi
abbiamo dimenticato di aver vissuto
quella stagione anche in italia o forse
no non l'abbiamo non l'abbiamo davvero
dimenticata quella costituzione creò la
repubblica come casa comune
la repubblica e la patria nostra l'unica
che i millenni di storia abbia davvero
abbracciato tutti gli italiani senza
esclusione senza distinzione di sesso di
razza di opinioni politiche di religione
di condizioni personali e sociali lo
scrive la costituzione
io la racconta una giornalista spesso
sventrata come il palazzo di via
d'amelio distrutto dall'autobomba di
paolo borsellino
la raccolto terremotata come in queste
settimane la sento aggredita sporcata
tradita imprecato maledetta bestemmiata
circondata dai lupi all'esterno è
assediata al suo interno dal rancore e
dalla sfiducia
il mio lavoro consiste nel fare memoria
nel combattere i cavalieri dell'attimo
presente
e la nostra repubblica e da ricostruire
perché una tensione che non finisce mai
è una missione da compiere 70 anni dopo
è un'eredità una rinascita una
rigenerazione aldo moro scrisse forse il
destino dell'uomo non è di realizzare
pienamente la giustizia ma di averne
perpetuamente fame e sete
ed è pur sempre un grande destino
l'aveva scritto da ragazzo incontro al
loro destino in europa e nel
mediterraneo sono andati due ragazzi
italiani
valeria solesin e giulio regioni e vanno
i ragazzi che arrivano da noi chi ha
fame sete chi cerca la giustizia chi
segue il suo destino
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
c'è
john c
swatch
[Musica]
anche il nome
no
[Musica]
questo cartone di makkox andato in onda
al termine di una puntata di gazebo e
come un grillo la vita come un salmo
come una rapsodia gex a un ritmo
sincopato e come ruggito dei leoni e
come il suono di quelle voci lontane di
70 anni fa e di quelle vicine oggi che
dovremo continuare ad ascoltare che
vorremmo continuare a ricordare per fare
memoria per rivivere per vivere